spoiler alert it is a dark time for
people who have not seen the last Jedi
as rotten tomatos posts a video
containing massive spoilers across the
galaxy rebel forces who have not seen
the last Jedi are being encouraged to
turn off this video right away so they
don't learn about all of the movies in
the secrets
okay if you're here then you've seen the
last Jedi or at least you don't mind the
fact that we're gonna talk about all the
cool stuff that happens right good good
boy or girl let's get started at the
fabulous casino in Kanto bite this fancy
shot is actually a classic movie
reference and I do mean classic it's
ripped right from the 1927 silent film
wings trivia wings won the very first
Academy Award for Best Picture of the
year
remember that bouncy jazz music playing
at the casino
it sort of recalls the cantina band from
moss eisely and just like that infamous
Tatooine spaceport ros warns finn that
the casino is filled with the worst kind
of people you know that old
something-something scum and villainy in
one of the film's most emotional moments
luke hands leia her late husband hans
prized golden dice these are the very
same dice that han used in the famous
game of sabacc in which he won the
Millennium Falcon off Lando Calrissian
he kept them in the cockpit of the
Falcon for luck they first appeared all
the way back in a new hope Depot large a
r2d2 at one point motivates Luke by
replaying Leia's old message for obi-wan
from a new hope and that other r2 unit
he purchased had a bad motivator so this
was definitely the right call Luke's a
smart shopper for obvious reasons the
last Jedi also features many many
callbacks to Luke's training on dig
about with Yoda or I guess features many
callbacks to Luke's training on Dagobah
it does with Yoda the last Jedi I'd
screwed that up
Rey has her own dark vision in a cave in
which she sees an alternate version of
herself just like luke's Dagobah was
also the last place that Luke spoke to
Yoda before his for spirit appears in
last Jedi the character himself done is
a practical effect more closely
resembles the cantankerous doddering old
Empire Yoda than the prequel version he
even knocks Luke on the head with his
cane fans of that moment in Return of
the Jedi when Obi Wan's ghost sits down
on a log what the Internet has termed
hashtag ghosts it will be really into a
similar moment in last Jedi when
illuminated ethereal presence of another
long dead Jedi needs to take a load off
for a minute or two
being dead seems exhausting locks it
baby locks
also on acto the remote planet where
Luke his training array we see that Luke
has stashed his x-wing underwater just
as it fell into the swamp in Dagobah
seeing an early help set up the film's
big climactic fake-out we think Luke has
flown his x-wing to create to rejoin
Leia and the resistance rather than just
you know meditating himself there
I guess that ability called forced
teleportation has appeared previously in
Star Wars TV shows video games in other
media but this was the first time we've
seen a Jedi do it in one of the films
and speaking of that amazing Luke finale
the dual Suns on the horizon recall his
introduction on Tatooine from a new home
this shot was also referenced with the
infant Luke at the end of Revenge of the
Sith Luke vanishing after he struck down
parallels Obi Wan's final moments in a
new hope where he allows Darth Vader to
take him down in front of his protege oh
and that very last scene with a little
boy retelling the epic story of Luke
Skywalker
c-3po did the same for the benefit of
the Ewoks and Return of the Jedi now we
know from a tie-in book that the little
boy with the broom is named to Miri blag
but we don't have any other information
about him is he the next Jedi Disney um
if you use this you have to pay me now
so much for callbacks to other Star Wars
movies but there are a lot of little fun
details in this movie to pick out as
well hey fans at the game battlefront 2
you're gonna notice the compass on the
bookshelf in Luke's bedroom on acto it's
the one he steals from the Emperor's
personal vault in the game and it's how
he found his way to this remote planet
to begin with did you get a look at the
insignia on the floor of the Jedi Temple
apparently the caretakers believe this
is an image of the very first Jedi known
as the prime jedi cuz it sounds cooler
it kind of looks like Snoke a little
right is there may be more to his story
after all maybe no what do you guys
think remember that guy who licks salt
on the ground on crate his buddy
standing next to him is rogue one
director Gareth Edwards in a little
cameo left over star justin theroux
shows up very very briefly as well in
Kanto bite as the master code breaker
who Finn and Rose never get a chance to
talk to it's just as well he looks busy
also in the Kanto bike casino a vocal
cameo from Warwick Davis who first
appeared in the Star Wars series as
wicket the Ewok in Return of the Jedi
another vocal cameo in the film
apparently belongs to a longtime Rian
Johnson collaborator Joseph
gordon-levitt but darn if we could pick
it out from all the straight dialogue
any ideas let us know what you think or
did you find it remember how in the
force awakens Daniel Craig made a brief
appearance and disguised as a
stormtrooper well the new film
quadruples down on the slyly disguised
villainous celebrity guest stars Bane
himself Tom Hardy Don's the first order
garb in a mystery scene as does take
that's Gary Barlow and get this Prince
William and Harry which star troopers
were they did their cameos even make it
in perhaps the film's most impressive
cameo happens at the bar in Kanto bite
this little guy in the background is
actually Carrie Fisher's beloved dog
Gary he's a very good boy oh you know
I'm very good whatever that thing is
the film introduces a ton of new gadgets
weapons and vehicles to the world of
Star Wars an actual ton we weighed them
these new fangled skimmers hover just
above the salt flats on the planet crate
and kind of resemble those speeder bikes
we saw back on the Endor moon they're
facing off against a brand new type of
heavy artillery the ATM 6 that stands
for the all-terrain mega caliber 6 and I
know you can't see me right now
but please believe that I just pushed my
glasses all the way up my nose up up in
outer space both the first-order and the
resistance show off some new vessels as
well the first-order dreadknot is that
massive battle cruiser poe dameron takes
out in the opening sequence this is the
debut of this weapon which he terms a
fleet killer the dreadnought faces off
against the BSF 17 heavy bomber aka the
resistance bomber which is much easier
to say for a refreshing change of pace
the first order didn't actually build a
new Death Star this time out but they do
have a new cannon integrating Death Star
technology which they used to crack the
reinforced wall at the resistance crate
base and lastly kylo ren's custom TIE
fighter which sort of resembles Darth
Vader's from undo hope gotten the
original ideas kylo and we just made an
easter egg video that's about as long as
a Star Wars movie so I'll take my leave
from you thanks for watching and
remember never trust a hacker that you
met in prison with your life this seems
kind of obvious guys